So Trisomy 21 or having three copies of
chromosome 21, is an example of aneuploidy, where
we gained a chromosome and this is referred
to clinically as Down's Syndrome. It's a disorder
which results in a delay of cognitive development,
physical growth as well a particular set of
facial features. Now monosomy X or XO, is
an example of aneuploidy from having lost a chromosome.
We only have one X chromosome and no Y chromosome or no other X chromosome. And
this is referred to as Turner's Syndrome, a
disorder with physical and hormonal abnormalities that result
in infertility. In general, aneuploidy has largely negative
effects. In fact, I haven't been able to
come up with one example where aneuploidy has
an overall net positive effect. Now for you advanced
learners out there, aneuploidy and polyploidy aren't
the same thing and there are net positive
effects to polyploidy. But if you can come
up with a good positive example, a net
positive example for aneuploidy, I would love it
if you go to the forums and post
it. I think we'd all like to see what a good example of that would be.